Sasha according to Metro they are
expecting a New Year's Eve like crowd
with this Championship parade tonight
and if you recall that number from this
past New Year's Eve was about 400 000.
now as for getting around both North and
southbound traffic on Las Vegas
Boulevard are closed between Flamingo
and Tropicana that includes all private
drives in between now the closure
started around three and they will
reopen once the celebration ends expect
a lot of traffic around this area as
people park there is parking at MGM
Resorts property it is event parking
rates and as for safety Metro officer
Robert Wicks sharing that they plan to
go over and Beyond to make sure people
are safe
we're going to have a visible presence
on the Strip that's going to be our plan
to make sure everybody sees the visible
presence and feels safe being on the
strip and we'll do we'll if any threats
come up we'll make sure that we
investigate them and do our best to head
anything off before it happens and in
addition no viewing of the parade will
be allowed on The Pedestrian Bridges as
they are shut down to pedestrians I know
chairs will be allowed on the parade
route or in Toshiba Plaza now there will
be water for sale and also complementary
cups of water at Food stands in the
plaza there will also be cooling
stations and porta potties there as well
so again while the parade starts at
seven there will be a rally on Toshiba
Plaza that's right by the Fortress that
starts at nine and is expected to last
until 10 so it's definitely going to be
a crowded area there probably until 11
or midnight Sasha yeah maybe even later
than that thank you Madison now this is
important as well what you can bring to
the parade and rally listen up because
of course the list is pretty detailed do
not take any large purses glass
containers cool coolers bags backpacks
fanny packs don't bring strollers carts
or drones now